what are your goals and expectations
coming into this event
i don't know just like last year i'm
coming after a very long layoff and
i'm just happy to play i'll try to do my
best
i don't have a sense of what my
expectations should be but
you know i've trained a little bit
hopefully it'll go well so i will just
have this feeling that
just to enjoy
playing here in my in my city and
playing against such a strong guys yeah
i mean i i need to do well um and for
the overall grand chess tour standings
um and of course ideally to win it would
be great and that would put me in a very
good position and also give me a
generally very good feeling you know
it's it's a super strong event so it's
not like
winning it is easy at all it's super
tough but
um but i have my hopes that that this
will be my
my my shop
yeah i hope you to perform very well
play my very best choice and just enjoy
the tournament
i don't put much pressure on myself i
just want to
you know feel um
joy and excitement and
yeah and it's all
always combined with a good result
so um yeah like last time i said
that i was hoping to survive the event
and it's pretty much the same since i
made so many one more blunders just
within a week a week ago so i think you
know
if i avoid
doing
repeating the same mistakes
i will be happy man regardless of the
yeah
results
i want to be able to
try to play some good chess like i mean
in romania i think i
played quite well
so i just want to continue that uh
you can't really predict who's gonna win
all that but you just want to play well
avoid making too many mistakes
the main goal is to eat all these
sandwiches
in the player's room yeah and maybe
50
in rapid section would be fantastic
result for me but it's very difficult to
predict when it's about bliss i'm told
for this part of the tournament
it's awesome that i'm playing here it's
a great great event it's
the
most important tour in the chess world
and uh hopefully i can live up to the
expert expectations and
i can play good chess and why not make a
few upsets
uh i would
rather try to win here because
i think in romania
we had
this misbehaving frenchman so
he is not here so we have to take
advantage of that and try wesley and i
we have to try to take advantage to get
in the ahead in the tournament list
[Music]